pyrite and will target
inclusive and sustainable socio-economic development
democracy good governance and
human rights rapprochement
between peoples mobility
migration and security the fight
against the fight against terrorism
we are committed to  to deepen our
privileged partnership and in particular
for the Tunisian youth who
expect concrete results and
real prospects for the future the
good holding of the municipal elections
just a week ago the
Tunisian government inviting us to observe
constitutes a major step in
democratic consolidation  of the country
I would also like to reaffirm here our
strong will and our efforts aimed
at concluding a comprehensive free trade agreement as
soon as possible Tunisia and the European Union
share the same objective of strengthening
regional stability and I welcome the
efforts  and the work of Tunisia in
this direction I would like to say  here that this
accompaniment precious financial support
will help us to establish and
local democracy
condition sine qua non of the success of
the democratic experience in tunisia
tunisia sees we have in europe not
only an
important partner at the economic level but
also a model a model of
democracy that we want and mules
to strengthen the democratic process
in tunisia
we expressed our common concern
for the deadlines well to get out of the situation
of lethargy in which we find ourselves
today the question is well helped
especially to accelerate  the
political process in this country we would like
the support of our European friends to
avoid escalation and above all to
meet the expectations of the
Palestinian people finally investment and
economics
this initiative comes up against a great job
no doubt the solution was born this type of
contract